Alright, let's do it together. The algorithm started out by assuming that the
tallest one is the one at position zero. Now, we want to visit all other
elements. For that, we can't really use the enhanced for loop, that would visit
all elements including the one at zero, which we no longer care about, so we'll
use a regular for loop. Here's the loop. Notice that i starts at one, and not
at zero, because we no longer want to look at the element at index zero. With
this loop, we only look to the index values, and we still need to get the
element at that value. Now we're ready to compare the current one against the
tallest one. That comparison is here. In that case, we change our mind, and say
the tallest one is no pic. When you run the code the tallest one will be
displayed, and it's this one. Let's move on to another algorithm.